movie myths about Biometrics Biometrics
and movies always entail some dramatic
and spectacular display of Technology
although in real life retina scanning
for example looks pretty boring do you
remember how in the film minority
reports the hero had to undergo an eye
transplant in order to escape in reality
this is an impossible trick because the
eyeball is connected to the optic nerve
and this nerve is directly connected to
the brain there's no point in
transplanting the eyeball because the
patient simply won't be able to see what
about fingerprint theft anyone can get
your fingerprint however it's extremely
difficult to use it the fact is that
modern biometric locks are able to
determine the temperature of the skin
the presence of a pulse in the finger
and other signs of life so you can't
fool them with a dummy by the way did
you know that getting a transplant of
someone else's fingers is also not the
best idea in theory after a certain time
your original fingerprint pattern will
return plus the risk of rejection of the
donor finger is high subscribe to our
channel to learn more interesting things
about cyber security